when i said crazy what were you
um
i look crazy what
um so i would say like no one heard that
go on um
like i literally like contacted him on
almost everything
and then just non-stop like calling
calling calling calling calling
then like basically when he did pick up
i was screaming at him i was like what
the [ __ ] do you think you're doing like
basically like you know i don't i feel
like like i would never
act like that normally i feel like yeah
anytime i act out of character i would
it's like say i'm acting crazy yeah
but that is your character then you
think so yeah because if if it's not in
you it can't come out of you
i guess
i mean
like do you not
so do not think that if like something
were to happen to you like you can
act some sort of way that
like you wouldn't normally act unless
you're in that you know specific
situation like you're just your emotions
are like to the max your stress levels
to the max like you know that it just
pushes you to a certain level i would
say i guess you could still say like i
acted how i would if i was in that
situation
like i probably would have been like
yeah
yeah like what you said like maybe you
didn't know it was you like you had it
in you
you found out about yourself that day
yeah
maybe you realize like
wow that's who i am yeah i think women
get to act crazy
you think we get to you get to actually
there's more of a um
a leniency with you acting crazier than
men acting crazy because if a man acts
crazy it's like what the [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] i have dated an emotional
night like yeah but do you think that's
do you think that's because women are
seen to be these like emotional
creatures yeah yeah but but that's some
it's one of those double standards isn't
it because like i know women that have
like smashed people's cars
you know like done all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] and it's like women going crazy if
a man wants to smash a woman's car
like people be like oh my god this guy
is [ __ ] toxic he's like
you know what i mean like he's getting
like
looked at in this in a different way
than women would yeah i agree with that
actually i think girls are given more of
a past thing yeah
crazy stuff but yeah i feel like that's
like the there's like a pro and con of
being men or women and so like you know
obviously being women i guess we get to
be a little more emotional whereas men
they get to be like more what is it
um
going
what what are you gonna say no i
i won't say that um women
aren't emotional but i think
men
are emotional it just shows a little
differently and i think the reason why
women may have a little bit more
leniency towards their emotion is
because
if a man is say if a man smashed
somebody's car the next thought that
they're gonna think like what are they
gonna do to me right it's just like a
fearful tactic because we've seen we
haven't seen any women
um the first thing that comes to my mind
is football player in the states he
literally picked up this woman i don't
know if it was wife girlfriend or
whatever and like
drag like threw her across the room like
she was a rag doll so it's just like
things like that i think comes like to
mind when a man
acts
their emotion is at that level to where
it's like crazy the thing is i've seen a
man do that to a woman but i've seen a
man do that to a woman
after she has
spat in his face
slapped him in his face
and been like what the [ __ ] you gonna do
you can't do [ __ ] but and i'm like
just that physical action of him doing
that
will in the general public's eyes make
him seem like the bad guy and people
will kind of negate what she done yeah
do you know i mean like i'm saying women
get to act crazy and if a man responds
to it it's like oh look at him it's like
did you not see all the [ __ ]
before it actually happened i don't i
don't like when women do that because
i'm like
i don't like men hitting women but it's
like you've put yourself in that
position like if if a woman if you did
that to a woman she would react
retaliate the same way but you dead to a
man so when a man react retaliates that
same way you wouldn't be like you
shouldn't hit women well don't don't
give him that lead way to retaliate in
that way because you don't know what's
inside a person to put them in that
position
right
i agree
no one should be hitting anyone at all
no one should be here like whoever hits
me i'm hitting them back i'm rocking
real hard and if you hit a man no a man
can hit you back you know it's just that
simple do you guys agree with that if
you if you punch a guy like he can punch
you back yeah i mean i feel like that's
just like completely unfair if like
women are just like
i don't know what are these other men
supposed to just stand there like yeah
how are they supposed to process their
emotions like just sit there and be like
and that's why that's why a lot of men
don't actually report domestic abuse
towards them
because they know it's not going to be
taken seriously it's like oh it's a
woman hit you what what what are you
going to say it's like no but you know
there are a lot of women out here out
there
actually physically abusing men and men
are taking it because they kind of know
that
it's not going to be taken seriously
that does bring up like you know like
the johnny dub case yeah what happened i
don't know that case
what was that actress's name
i forget her name but i remember the
recordings it was just like
yeah
she um
i think she was just like abusive
mentally and physically towards
and
i think she filed a case against him
being abusive towards her
but then i forget what exactly happened
but then obviously like he won the case
but when she was abusing him like you
could hear the recording she was like no
one's going to believe you anyway no
one's going to believe you they'll just
you know people are going to think that
did he win he did okay and like i think
there were like some videos coming up
like where she would just like randomly
raise her hand and he'd like flinch
and it's oh man it's just so sad
it was her and not him but that's not
generally at all not him that's
generally believed though yeah do you
know what i mean it's generally believed
that it's going to be him he's going to
be the man that's going to be the abuser
there was a moment where he kind of got
blackballed in like the acting community
or whatever because people actually
believe the others yes exactly well and
that's the thing i i feel like when a
girl accuses a guy of something
like people just automatically assume
like like what is it believe believe all
women believe all women but i'm like
some of these girls are crazy like you
can't you can't believe all girls i've
been i've been accused of
of hitting a woman really yeah i've been
accused what happened
um i've been accused of pushing a woman
down two flights of stairs
i had to go to court for it oh my god
i got found not guilty
but it's just the fact that
i was there you were there
there was no injuries like what are you
talking about like we we may have had an
argument yeah right but
what like what are you talking about but
because women generally know they can
call the police and be believed
they have to investigate and i'm like so
what was her evidence there wasn't any
it was it was it was literally my word
against against hers
and so
yeah yeah
yeah with that i got found not guilty
because they had they only delivered
they only deliberated for like 10
minutes
and they were like
that's just so like disrespectful to
like all women that have been exactly
thankful
it's just like oh it's just so
disappointing
like for women to even have the courage
to stand up because it's very like
frowned upon on different like aspects
and it's so hard yeah it is hard it's so
hard as an individual to stand up and be
like this is what happened to me and
actually stand up again to prosecute
another person for what they did to you
and they don't get found guilty because
of women that do lie and exaggerate
their situation
for their own benefit
um
and they you know what i mean and it
just it looks bad on other women that
actually do get go for the thing it's
the reason why i can be accused like me
like okay i'm six foot two
i'm black and yeah you know what i mean
it's easy to believe that i am always
going to be the aggressor you know what
i mean so was it can i ask um what race
your
double black they're all black there's a
black one young black woman yeah as a
black woman and so but but she's a woman
and so she's going to be believable
women
right she's going to be believed right
and it's like well
if i have like no
history of abusing women and that this
just comes out of the blue for me i know
i'm like what are you talking about but
it doesn't matter that really doesn't
matter when they can't undo the
character assassination like there might
be people that like believe like there
was a case where a dude was um
he was
a girl said that she she was assaulted
by him and it came out that she lied but
like you can't undo everyone on campus
thinking he was a rapist for like oh
great gotta say great but like for um
great because you can't say
great
yeah
um for two years you know because or
however long the trial is
um
yeah that does
has there ever been a case where the guy
sues like the woman for defamation
i don't know but i know there was a case
in america where
a woman said that um a guy graped her
[Music]
she um but it came to find out that she
dreamt it
was it was okay yeah she dreamt it but
he actually went to prison for it really
he went to prison for grape yeah but how
did they find out she jumped like
because i think afterwards like
afterwards he appealed and
have you heard of it yeah like she she
dreamt it did she actually believe it
happened to her though
i don't know i i don't believe it i
think i bet she just knew they must have
looked into her psychology
team also going to psychiatric unit she
would have got evaluated if that was the
case that that would have been the
procedure do you think that she was like
too far like she started singing and she
realized it was a dream and she was like
too far in it and she couldn't she like
was too embarrassed to take i don't i
don't know but i think she should go to
jail i think any girl that like does
that should go to jail even if you
retract because you're like oh i'm sorry
like it was my mistake but remember
though when those kind of cases happen
we know the man
you're right don't know the woman like
everything is put out about the man he's
in the press he's in the papers he's on
social media he was accused of this
thing and it's like who's the woman no
one knows but i think nowadays nowadays
they do know who the woman is because
they do tell like both stories but her
her character is not assassinated like
his it's like a man if if a man is
accused of anything like that he's
finished it doesn't even matter we did
it or not yes he's finished but would
you
can you argue the other way where they
do
like say like oh this woman like she
does go out drinking she likes to wear
all this and this she's like barely
wears any clothes wear high heels but it
doesn't mean you should be like well
obviously but i mean don't you wouldn't
you say like they're like what is it the
media is basically trying to blame the
woman yeah and that's and that's the
thing that's why when i hear
me personally when i hear that men have
been accused of something like this
i just
wait for all the evidence to come out
i'm not saying he did it didn't do it
i'm not saying she's lying she's not
lying i'm just like let me just wait to
see but people generally there was a
case um in the uk last year there was a
woman um
i actually spoke about it there was a
old lady who killed her husband right
she was like penelope jackson was her
name penelope jackson she killed her
husband and when the police came
and because they had their body cameras
and they um they filmed it she was so
not she was like yeah he deserved it he
was an abuser and he done this and blah
blah blah and because she said that yeah
all the women just jumped to her defense
yeah she must have been going through so
much she must she must have been pushed
to the edge come to find out when it got
to a jury she got 18 years for killing
him because she was lying but the thing
is is that it doesn't really matter
it's the fact that she said it
and women just believed her yeah
and that's that do you know what i mean
that that's that and yeah you're you're
now guilty into you you're proven
innocent when you when something like
that happens
or even with that like supreme court
justice at the u.s um what was it um
you know i'm talking about the supreme
court justice a couple years back
where that girl like came out
um and said he assaulted her in college
right as he became like he was nominated
for the court yes
and the media the media like painted him
as such a bad guy but if you watch the
full like interrogation and like the
trial and stuff
they found nothing on him and the whole
world
like they see him as a rapist well
the president of the united states
currently
has a allegation against him from a
woman called tara reed and we haven't
even heard about it tara reid
joel biden has been accused by a woman
named tara reed of digitally inserting
his fingers in her while he was in
office that's the case no one hears
about it